- So here's some hashtag not legal advice
for people that are engaging
in tons and tons of criminality.
If someone asks you to write down a list
of all of the crimes
that you have committed,
even if you're trying to get a pardon,
maybe don't write those down,
but that advice is apparently
too late for Joel Greenberg
who apparently asked Roger
Stone to get a pardon for him
from former President Donald
Trump and in the process
of doing so, he wrote
down all of the crimes
that he and his friend
Congressman Gaetz had engaged in
that would obviously require
a pardon from the President.
So, yeah, here's the
thing, don't do that, ever.
Do not ever write down all
the crimes that you have done
even if you're seeking
a pardon, but you know,
hashtag not legal advice.
So we'll probably see that guy in court.